pas besoin d'être un voyant pour prédire
que les performances des athlètes russes
au cours de ces jeux olympiques à l'être
draper d'à priori négatif en effet
permettre aux athlètes russes de
défendre leur chance à tokyo en dépit
d'une suspension de quatre ans pour un
prétendu programme de dopage a créé la
polémique
et pourtant sur un nombre réduit
d'athlète a été autorisé à participer
qui plus est sous bannière neutre ce qui
veut dire sans drapeau centimes pour des
athlètes qui officiellement ne sont même
pas russe et du comité olympique de
russie
par contre ils ont bien eu droit aux
questions impartiale et équilibrée des
journalistes
les athlètes
keep olympique russe porte-t-il les
stigmates des tricheurs dans ces jeux
après le scandale qu'en pensez vous
pour la première fois de ma vie je ne
répondrai pas une question dans une
interview c'est la première fois de ma
vie
vous devriez avoir honte de votre
question je ne veut plus revoir cette
personne en zone mixte de toute ma vie
je ne veux pas répondre à ces questions
il faudrait peut-être que vous fassiez
en sorte qu'ils ne soient pas présents
aux jeux olympiques
il semble en effet que la russie profite
d'un traitement de faveur de la part de
la presse en particulier anglo saxon à
croire que tous ces titres pensait que
les athlètes russes n'allait rien
pouvoir faire sans leur dopage
institutionnalisée du côté des athlètes
le fair play et la sportivité ne sont
pas toujours de mise
comme par exemple avec la rameuse
américaine megan calmeau et après s'être
retrouvé derrière la paire russe en
finale du deux sans barreur elle s'est
fendu d'un tweet rageur le fait de voir
une équipe qui ne devrait même pas être
là repartir avec une médaille d'argent
laisse un sentiment désagréable c'est
vraiment décevant d'une manière générale
et j'ai de la peine pour les autres
athlètes de la finale à
un autre athlète américain fait grise
mine le nageur ryan murphy
arrivé lors de deux finales près le
russe rilov a déclaré à chaud que la
course n'était probablement pas propre
même s'il s'est depuis rétractée entre
temps un agent britannique troisième de
la course a lui aussi fait une remarque
similaire sur le dopage
des accusations indirectes ok le comité
olympique russe a tenu à réagir
c'est incroyable de voir à quel point
nos victoires dérange certains de nos
collègues du monde du sport oui nous
sommes là aux jeux olympiques et nous y
avons parfaitement droit que cela leur
plaise ou non il faut savoir perdre mais
ce n'est pas le cas de tout le monde et
on reprend le vieux refrain sur le
dopage russe est quelqu'un essaie de
faire en sorte que cette rengaine ne
s'arrête pas quoi qu'il en soit les
athlètes russes peuvent compter sur le
soutien de tout un pays mais aussi des
autorités
nos athlètes doivent remporter des
médailles de préférence d'or peut
ignorer tout cela les médaillés sont au
dessus de la critique
je lis et regarde les médias occidentaux
la participation de la russie aux jo de
tokyo les mets tout simplement hors
d'eux tous les irrite les médailles
remportées par nos athlètes leur
uniforme
l'imperturbable ilité de l'équipe face à
toutes les intrigues et attaque le
soutien populaire apporté à notre
sélection est désormais aussi les
symboles russe sur les t-shirts des
journalistes j'ai l'impression qu'ils
vont bientôt commencer à envier les
anneaux olympiques sur l'uniforme et le
drapeau de notre équipe nationale
absent des leurs les athlètes russes
invités à participer à ces jeux ont été
triés sur le volet et contrôlée de très
près par les institutions anti dopage
ils le doivent donc leur performance
qu'à eux mêmes
n'en déplaise aux sportifs frustrés et à
la presse rabat joie